hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and i don't need to point out the
obvious here but i am talking to you
right now you are listening we are
engaging
in a communication act mediated by
speech by vocalizations
this is something that human beings can
do we can talk to each other we have the
power of
language so where did that come from
is it common in the animal kingdom is it
common in uh
other species you know well yes and no
and this is what we're gonna get into in
today's podcast eric jarvis
is a leading scientist he's at
rockefeller university who studies the
origins of language
and vocal learning and how they arise
not only in
human beings but in other species
especially in birds
birds are have a several of the other
species where
vocal learning the ability to learn new
sounds
is a common trait and you might think
that well you know i talk to my
dog and my cat you know you can give
instructions to horses or elephants or
whatever
but that's not quite language and the
interesting
distinction is that dogs and cats can
bark and meow
but they can't learn new sounds those
sounds that they have to communicate
with
they're born with more or less i mean
maybe they learn to meow but they always
had the ability
to do it right and so it's a very small
number of species that actually has the
ability to
learn new sounds and then put them to
use
in communicating with each other as
we'll go through i'm not going to give
away
all the fun things that happen in the
podcast but in addition to a few mammal
species
there's several species of birds you
know about parrots parakeets
uh hummingbirds also and so forth have
this ability to learn
new sounds so one question is you know
why is this ability so rare it seems
kind of useful
right and then why do we human beings in
particular put it to use
in the way that we do you know parakeets
don't make grammatically complicated
sentences
in the same way that human beings do and
eric is a wonderful person to talk to
because he kind of studies this problem
on all different levels you know he will
record birdsong and sort of analyze it
uh has plenty of birds in his lab
he will also do genetic analysis
comparing the genes between different
species
and then he will also do sort of brain
level analysis
looking into the brains of the birds and
other species to see what's going on and
the hypothesis is that there's literally
a motor circuit
in the brain that was sort of borrowed
from other motor circuits maybe what we
used
to move our hands or our faces or
something like that that was repurposed
to really just
focus in on making new sounds and he
claims that by looking both at the genes
and at the structure of brains you can
see similarities
in the brains of parakeets and human
beings
that you don't see if you compare you
know parakeets to falcons
or human beings to chimpanzees we
share this ability which is kind of rare
and interesting and
it's fun if you want if you have time i
recommend sticking around to the end of
this podcast because we start
hypothesizing on
some fun things and some new ideas and
that's
what makes science and podcasting in
their intersection pretty great because
we can
let our hair down a little bit we can
talk about ideas that bring in lots of
different
points of view and maybe something new
and interesting happens there
certainly talking about things is an
important part of what we do
so knowing how that happens knowing why
we do it knowing how to make it better
maybe even give that ability to new
species
is something we should know more about
so let's go
[Music]
eric jarvis welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you
so we're interested in spoken language
uh in humans and other species and so
forth so here's my question every
morning
5 a.m i'm asleep in bed and my cat ariel
climbs on top of me and starts meowing
and this is clearly a vocalization
that is meant to communicate something
namely uh she is hungry and it is
breakfast time
but i think that by the standards of
what you're interested in this does not
count as a spoken language or um
vocal learning so what what is the
difference between just you know
communicating by making sounds and what
you're interested in
yeah so that meow coming from the cat uh
that's a natural ability that is it's
born with like our eye color
height and so forth where there's uh
it's mostly genetically uh predetermined
the cat can learn how to use a meow in
different
contexts like for food right water
we call that vocal music learning but
not vocal production learning which is
the ability to produce
novel sounds that you're not born to be
able to produce
okay so it's not just a matter of
the meaningfulness of the sound so other
plenty of species
have meaningful communication via sounds
but you're interested in
learning new sounds that's correct
so learning new sounds that you copy
from other
people or you can even modify i mean
imitate sounds that you hear in your
environment
so it's the ability to actually modulate
the acoustic structure
and the sequence of the sounds that you
produce
okay and that's one component of what we
call spoken language i mean maybe it'll
be useful just to put things in context
to talk about what the other components
of spoken language are like many things
that we're very familiar with it's a
simple thing that actually has a lot of
different moving parts
that's right yeah we humans don't
realize that spoken language
has multiple components to it of course
i just mentioned one of them vocal
production learning
another is auditory learning and
this component actually pretty common uh
like it
uh pet animals like a dog can learn how
to understand
what the meaning of the word sit means
and actually sit or
in other languages like siente say in
spanish
uh or you know get the ball the
newspaper get this toy and so forth
so this is necessary for spoken language
because
we need to form an auditory memory of
what we're going to imitate in our
speech
but it's not deficient right and so
i mean so i can even so you're saying
that we have auditory learning and vocal
production learning so or
sorry vocal usage learning is the thing
that the cat has
no uh vocal uses learning is common
where you learn how to use a sound in
different contexts even innate sounds
it's vocal production learning or just
more simply vocal learning itself
that's very rare and
auditory learning that i just mentioned
as a second component
is actually common are there i mean it
sounds like to me like auditory learning
the ability to
hear and understand and vocal usage
learning the ability to make a noise and
be understood those would be pretty
closely correlated are there species
that have one but not the other
yeah yeah so uh like i mentioned that
you know dogs have the ability of
vocal uh auditory learning i'm sorry but
without the
vocal production learning but they have
local usage learning you said right
although say it again sorry i'm trying
to figure out whether or not
a species can have auditory learning but
not
vocal usage learning ah yes okay
uh that's not really been tested but i
doubt
that they have those two separate i bet
you
um for most species it's going to be
they have both
except for some lizards that don't
vocalize at all
ah so they can hear and understand
sounds but they don't make them
that's correct interesting they don't
make them at least through their vocal
tract
okay and interesting yeah all right so i
and i think that uh
one of the slippery things is that
because things like cats and dogs or
horses or whatever
um have this auditory learning and vocal
usage learning
we think of that as just a primitive
form of speech
right and then you know it's just a sort
of a continuum all the way up to what we
have but
and probably i'm guessing that in most
people's minds the real difference
is the idea of symbolic uh
language right the idea that we make a
sound and the sound doesn't have any
intrinsic meaning but we associate it
with something uh
and is that something that dogs and cats
can have
yeah so that's the surprising thing is
that
um that these species that don't have
spoken language or don't have vocal
learning can still
have symbolic understanding to a certain
degree
so uh you know getting back to dogs you
can you can teach them
to understand the meaning of different
uh objects
or in and even whole human sentences
uh but uh or even
even in a vervet monkey you can uh get
them to
not you just get them they do this
naturally out in the wild
where they all associate even some of
their innate sounds with an eagle in the
sky
or a snake on the ground different
innate sounds will mean different things
that they
culturally pass on from one generation
to the next but the ability to modify
those sounds is the names
interesting and so how what is the
evidence that they culturally pass it on
and that's fascinating
yeah this work of scifi and cheney where
um
it's i won't say it's solid evidence but
circumstantial but it's still
it's indicative of it where uh young
animals uh will respond to all different
kinds of
alarm calls that the adults make and
through experience
with the adults they learn that they
should re let's say run up in the tree
with this particular alarm call
or stay on the ground with this other
one or go to some other tree with food
with this particular call
uh they're not born with that
understanding they have to learn it
through experience
with their own kind interesting and it
is is the famous case of coco
the gorilla uh an example of this where
uh
i mean depending on what literature you
read it was anywhere from two thousand
to seven thousand words that coco
understood okay i think it was seven
thousand can understood about one to two
thousand
that she could sign with hands but not
with the voice
uh so uh that's a lot for a non-human
animal
even though our vocabulary is twenty
thousand words it's still
two to seven thousand is a lot it is a
lot i mean but i've heard yeah that
there are like coco truthers who think
that uh her abilities were exaggerated a
little bit
um yeah i don't know it could be
uh i don't want to say yes or no to that
i will say that just putting it in
relative
perspective coco can't even utter a
single word
right right so whether it's one thousand
or two thousand or seven thousand words
from
understanding not even a single word
from production
uh is is a huge difference and is coco
or our other
uh um non-human animals before we get to
the vocal stuff which is obviously what
we're going to focus on but
what about grammar uh is that something
that other animals animals know about
yeah i i don't want i don't i would say
no there's not enough evidence to
indicate that coco
had a grammar but it's hard
to even in the linguistic community it's
hard to i think
you know really define what what you
would call grammar and syntax
uh in a non-human animal just to say
i'm going to use the more simple word i
consider it more simple as syntax
where there is a non-random ordering of
sounds
vocal learners do that there are some
rules
that are there and a grammar where
there's a higher order
rule-based organizing of those sounds uh
i don't think there's good evidence for
that
yet uh because uh one one reason is that
i don't think it's been thoroughly
tested yet
okay good yeah one of the goals of the
podcast is to inspire
you know young people who are not yet
graduate students doing work to you know
pick some good problems so that sounds
like one that is worth
tackling i would agree and then we get
to
the vocal learning part which is which
is uh what we care mostly about here and
it's just
it's just interesting to me the the
connection that i get from reading your
stuff
between the physical ability to learn to
make different sounds
and the communication ability uh that we
have so so
what is this vocal learning thing why do
we care about it so much
yeah um so it's the ability to hear
the sounds i mean to its ability to not
only form the auditory memories of the
sounds that you hear but then to
actually repeat them and to
not only repeat simple sounds like
individual phonemes like
but to actually produce whole sequence
of sounds and words and so forth
and you asked about recombining them in
species from the auditory domain from
the hearing domain
but um you do get that in like some
parrots where they can take
learned human speech sounds and
recombine them into new words or new
meanings
uh that wasn't taught to them
so um so yes so this
ability it varies from one species to
another being simple in some and more
complex than others
i mean so many species can make sounds
of different forms it seems
almost surprising that the ability to
learn how to make new sounds is so rare
yeah yeah so exactly and it's so rare
and that rareness does come along with
differences in the biology
getting back to your original question
which is
we find that the species that can
produce learned sounds
have a specialized forebrain circuit
that you don't find in the species that
can't
and that circuit actually has a lot of
similarities with brain pathways that
control
learning how to move right so therefore
maybe it was hard to evolve it
yeah yeah i think it's yeah it's and
it's not just one brain region it's a
whole circuit
right okay so i think it's it's
interesting how to think about this
whether it's heart evolving
or it's hard to keep it if you evolve it
the curators at bespoke post have done
it again this winter
with an all new lineup of essential box
of awesome collections
guaranteed to upgrade your life whether
it's showcase pieces to level up your
indoor hosting skills
or cozy threads for those blustery days
bespoke post only sends you the best
stuff every month
no matter what you're into box of
awesome has you covered from styling and
grooming goods to bar wear
cooking tools and outdoor gear box of
awesome has collections for every part
of your life
i personally got what amounts to a
little tiny indoor fire pit
that you can put on your coffee table or
your dining room table to cozy up the
room a little bit
so to get started take the quiz at box
of awesome.com
your answers will help them pick the
right box for you they release new boxes
every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up you can skip a
month
cancel any time each box costs only 45
bucks but has over 70 dollars worth of
gear inside
so get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at
box of awesome.com and enter the code
mindscape at checkout that's box of
awesome.com
code mindscape for 20 off your first box
i mean i guess maybe for the for the
benefit of the audience out there
how many species we talking about here
who who counts i mean uh
people count but who else yeah
so we're talking uh five out of the 30
or so different orders of mammals
you know i think it's close to 50 of the
orders of mammals and that's
us humans actually amongst us humans
it's only amongst the primates that is
it's only humans
right then you have the cetaceans those
are the whales and dolphins
and they're multiple vocal learners
within the group you have the
bats who produce in the ultrasonic range
that we can't hear
and you have the pinnipeds um who are
like the sea lions
and seals so uh
so it's just those groups and they don't
have close relatives oh i forgot one
more which is the um
uh the elephants all right and amongst
birds
monk spurs are three of them parrots
sombers and hummingbird and the rest of
the 40-something bird lineages don't
have vocal learners
and that's just a uh never a list
anyone would guess on the basis of
anything else i mean they're they're not
so like we're much closer to chimpanzees
or monkeys but
uh it's bats and parrots that can have
this that share this ability with us
that's right it almost seems random but
i
i think there's an association with
predations
i think the the vocal learners
um are at for at least amongst mammals
are near the top of the food chain
and i think if you evolve this trait
you're producing varied sounds
that predators have a hard time
habituating to and you're more likely to
be eaten
i'll believe that for elephants and
whales you'll have to convince me that
for bats and and parakeets uh that
they're
on top of the food chain right so bats
they're in the ultrasonic range where
a lot of other species can't hear them
uh
and for some birds and parrots i didn't
have a good
rationale there either until we back in
2014 we created a phylogenetic tree of
birds using whole genomes
and discovered that they descended from
apex
predator birds back at the time of
dinosaurs
who were um uh who were called giant
terrorbirds by the paleontologists
so okay so are little parrots parrots
and parakeets are they both
and hummingbirds you said hummingbirds i
don't see that they have
an ancestry with uh uh being apex
predators and
yeah they're the smallest animals
they're pretty fast though at evading
predators so that i think we can give
them that
uh you know they're some of the fastest
flying birds besides you know falcons
so the birds that you mentioned are the
only non-mammals that have this ability
yes it's only a group of mammals and a
group of birds
uh so you know so there's 70 000
uh vertebrate species and many of them
are fish frogs amphibians reptiles
and of course these bird and
mammal groups and of those 70 000
species you know you can put them in
roughly 260 orders
okay right and so of those 260 orders
eight of them
are the vocal earners interesting and do
the i mean the birds just
seem like an outlier you know we can see
even though mammals are
seem very different from each other
they're at least all mammals do these
birds have
other abilities we would qualify as
linguistic
yeah i would say uh the closest you get
to that is in the parrots
um where where they will learn
actually human speech words and do uh re
new recombinations of them
i see so they'll make new words do they
do they make sentences
yeah they make sentences yes okay and
and
to to convey meaning because they want
something to happen
yeah so like i i once talked to an owner
of a
of the famous parrot parakeet is
basically a small parrot
that's what it means okay um who uh
learned about 400 human words besides
his own marvel phone
and uh he would uh basically uh produce
those words
in new combinations in about 75
70 percent of the time uh they seem
random just random combinations of words
and 30 in time to the listening humans
they made sense
a new combination of words in a new
situation that made sense
hmm are we are we worried that that's
the human's ability to see
patterns where they don't exist uh no
because i irene pepperberg who's
done some work on african grey parrots
uh doing uh
experimental analysis of this
demonstrates that this happens in a non
random manner it's statistically
significant that
uh her parents were producing words and
combination words
inappropriate social context i mean we
tend to
val we you know we're look we're human
beings we tend to think that we're
awesome and we're at the top of
everything
and the ability to do language and
speech is is one of our
you know most important traits uh
is it is there some kind of intelligence
that parakeets and parrots and
hummingbirds have
that uh we're not giving them credit for
or is there just a looser connection
between vocal learning and intelligence
that we might have guessed
uh well overall i think we humans
overrate ourselves
and therefore thereby underrate other
animals yeah including the non-vocal
learners
uh but among the vocal learners there is
some anecdotal evidence that
the more the more learned kind of
communication we do
in humans and parrots and songbirds
including like crows
who are a songbird that there is a
greater
intelligence but i'm going to say more
of a social intelligence than anything
than other kinds of intelligence and i
think this is brought on because of the
greater capacity for
learned communication so i've certainly
seen you know these demonstrations of
crows
solving puzzles that are that are quite
impressive right
yes and is that but are crows they're
not vocal learners were they in the in
their they actually are vocal learners
they don't
they don't actually have a let's say
they don't have a really
loud advertising song like mary uh would
have
but they do produce low volume song
in the bushes to each other and their
crows
they're the crowing vocalizations that
they produce that you can hear that's
pretty loud
is also learned okay and
uh there have been cases where crows
have picked up
human speech sounds all right good yeah
so yeah and the crows are definitely
clever there's definitely some
intelligence there
but i mean maybe even though we've said
it it's worth emphasizing um
the that other primates don't have this
ability so
and they are quite intelligent so
therefore there's clearly something
physiological
that is a little bit different between a
human being and a chimpanzee or a
gorilla
yes there is there's something different
physiological in the brain of course
parts of the body as well but it's
mostly when it comes to what we call
intelligent behavior in speech it's in
the brain
and it's this specialized circuit that i
told you about
but there's some other differences as
well uh one is that
in humans we have an extra copy of a
gene called srgap2
and this extra copy causes the neurons
to stay in a more
immature state throughout our lives
and that more immature state is argued
to allow us to learn more readily
throughout our lives
i think i'll add we all forget more
we as well because of that than other
species
conversely in parrots and and some birds
the vocal learning birds
uh they don't have an extra copy of this
gene uh but they do have
a high a greater twice the density of
neurons
packed in the same amount of space as a
non-vocal learning species
and i think that this doubling of
neurons in the brain
without increasing brain size that
dramatically allows them to have
more extra brain circuits for vocal
learning and other behaviors
i see so is it not is it more neurons
overall or just in the sort of
vocalization area
it's more neurons overall which then
uh i and some others will argue allows
the capacity
to have more neurons dedicated to vocal
behavior
okay and is it just uh the brain or is
the difference between us
and you know chimpanzees or whatever
also in our mouths and lungs and
larynxes
yeah so there is there's been an
argument out there for many decades now
uh sorry by lieberman who argued that
the descent of the larynx
allows humans to produce a lot greater
variety of sounds in other
primates or animals overall and the work
of tecumseh fitch has shown that this is
not true
ah okay that um other
animals when they raise their heads up
can get their larynx descended as low as
humans
and there are some animals that
independently evolve the descended
larynx in some lions
but yet they don't imitate sounds and
produce speech like we do
so uh i i don't i think the evidence for
that is pretty weak or not there at all
actually evidence against the difference
in the vocal organelle
makes the ability for speech okay but is
it is this one of these things where we
see an evolution where
multiple things had to happen so it
sounds like you need that ability to
vocalize and then you also need the
brain circuits to
put it to work in learning things yeah i
think i think um
multiple things did happen but i think
including maybe some modifications
peripheral organs but i don't think it's
the descent of larynx
and for example uh in the fifth lab they
they show that if you take a postmortem
uh
larynx of a um of a macaque a
monkey basically and blow air through it
in different patterns and so forth
you can get that larynx to produce all
kinds of sounds and phonemes like a
human larynx would
right right uh so and it doesn't matter
like how far away you blow the air
you know through that larynx in terms of
its descent
okay so i guess you could imagine why
evolution would
like the animal to have the ability to
make all sorts of different sounds
whether or not it was for
speech in particular or or language or
something like that
right yeah yeah yeah i think it's like
for example what
there are two reasons why we think
parrots
can produce more complex learned sounds
than
other vocal learning birds like
songbirds and hummingbirds
one is because they use the tongue more
than the other species like we use our
tongues not just our larynx to modulate
the sounds
uh second is they parrots and humans
have an extra brain pathway it's like a
a song system within a thorn system
that controls this behavior so an extra
brain pathway is
literally extra neurons or a different
wiring diagram for the existing
existing neuron it's both it's extra
neurons
plus some differences in the wiring of
those extra neurons compared to
the original vocal learning pathway that
we think they began with
okay and does this this relates to the
motor circuit that you uh
talked about earlier yep what we think
is that
initially a motor learning pathway
duplicated and gave rise to a vocal
learning pathway
and then in humans and in some birds and
nuts on birds humans
and parrots that new vocal learning
pathway duplicated again
and gave rise to a second one wow okay
and and by duplicating you'll forgive me
i'm just a
innocent physicist here uh is this that
sounds hard to do just like a duplicate
motor pathway in your in your brain is
that the kind of thing that arises all
the time or was that a really weird
thing
yeah i yeah i think it is hard to
conceptualize how that happens
uh and one way i think about is like a
gene replication
in the genome one gene get copied into
another
while the cell is undergoing cell
division right
okay so there's an accidental copy and
that accidental copy then gets
incorporated as a new
copy of that genome so i'm proposing
here a new theory
that maybe brain circuits actually can
duplicate
also during development and maybe
duplicating these circuits is a natural
process
right so that one motor circuit controls
the hand the other controls the feet the
chest
and so forth and now duplicate it again
and controlled the wirings in the time
so i guess i mean yeah now that i'm
thinking about it and you're talking
about it um
the idea that you have in your genome
a blueprint for making a certain kind of
motor circuit and then you just
have some transcription error or
whatever that duplicates it is
easier to imagine maybe than starting
from scratch and building a new one
exactly that that's how i'm thinking
about it that's how i think it
that's the hypothesis i have about how
it evolves
and is there some specific
uh motor circuit that did exist that is
the one that got duplicated
to help us control uh vocal learning or
we don't know
um the i have two alternative views on
that
one is that i think it is specific uh
it's either the circuit that controls
the oral facial musculature
or the circuit that controls the hands
right
okay that'd be very different yeah yeah
and the reason why i say the oral facial
musculature because
one of these circuits in the human brain
is
kind of next to or kind of you know
intermingled with the
oral facial musculature circuit that you
can find in other species
the other isn't right right the other
one is directly adjacent to the hand
area of the cortex and the human brain
okay
and um and even before you know my group
came up with this
hypothesis it was argued the hand
gesture theory of language origins where
you know
it's recognized that we humans even as i
talk to you and maybe as you talk to me
nobody can see us but i'm using my hands
to explain
what i'm saying is that we naturally use
gesturing and learn gesturing each
language has its own
learned gestures of the hands no i
absolutely do i'm constantly apologizing
for
you know trying to explain things using
my hands as i know perfectly well that
i'm on video i'm
on audio and not video so all right and
and that
and all also is that is that this sort
of the same fact or a related fact to
the idea that
these the hand control part of your
brain is near to the vocal control part
yeah i think that's that's partly the
one explanation that could explain the
use of hands that
that the duplicated from the hand
gesturing areas so you can get coco and
other primates to end some other animals
to communicate with
gestures using their hands or using
their wings
uh and so uh yeah maybe there's
there's a close relationship there and
it's maintained that relationship after
a duplicated
hand circuit 2020 has already reshaped
how we work and it's almost over
businesses across the globe are
challenged to be their most efficient
which means every
hire is critical and indeed is here to
help
indeed is the number one job site in the
world with more total visits than any
other job site
unlike other sites indeed gives you full
control and payment flexibility over
your hiring
you only pay for what you need you can
pause your account at any time and there
are no
long-term contracts and now indeed's new
way of matching you with candidates
instantly delivers a short list of
quality candidates whose resumes on
indeed match your job criteria that you
can contact the moment you sponsor a job
making indeed the only job site that can
move as fast as you do
right now indeed is offering our
listeners a free 75 dollar credit to
boost your job post
which means more quality candidates will
see it fast
try indeed out with a free 75 credit at
indeed.com
mindscape this is their best offer
available anywhere
indeed.com mindscape valid through
december 31 terms and conditions apply
and i guess the the the part i'm missing
is i i totally
think that i understand the idea that
there's a motor control circuit it gets
duplicated
it helps us control our vocalizations
but
its relationship to learning i guess i'm
missing is that is it a particular kind
of circuit that that helps us learn or
does it just
communicate and cooperate with other
parts of the brain
yeah i'm proposing this is a motor
learning circuit and what do i mean by
motor learning
i mean learning the brain controlling
body parts to learn how to move muscles
in certain ways
i see learning how to play the piano
with the fingers
learning how to walk or do dancing
right got it that this circuit exists
not not exactly dancing to music that's
another thing
but but to learn how to like circus
animals learning how to do tricks
that learning how to move your body in
different ways
is now controlling the larynx
i see yeah good a light bulb just went
off in my brain i mean clearly all these
different kinds of species
have some learning capacities and
clearly they also have some motor
control capacities but that doesn't
guarantee that they're sort of linked up
like we can't control our heart rate or
something like that right
right exactly but you're saying that we
developed the ability to
apply our learning abilities to our
vocalization abilities
that's right right exactly using similar
type of muscle fibers
but now it's muscles that produce the
voice and
produce sound and it does seem still
remarkable to me
that it happens in such wildly different
uh species as birds and humans this is
obviously a case of completely
independent evolution right
right exactly and i think that it's kind
of like that
you can get evolution to do the same
thing multiple times
uh and it's kind of like the evolution
of wings
uh they evolve in bats in birds
some ancient flying dinosaurs uh and
each time it's at the sides of the body
not one on the head one on the foot or
somewhere else because the center of
gravity there's
this selection pressure right you need
to have a center of gravity in the sky
you need something to be aerodynamic so
nature is selecting for this trade
and i think it's the same thing when it
comes to spoken language
yeah i mean we've had some uh biologists
evolutionary biologists on the show
before and one of the
the themes that keeps coming up is on
the one hand
evolution natural selection involves
some random changes trying out new
things but on the other hand
there's still laws of physics and design
principles and so forth and so you need
to find the right solution and it might
be found
in different times by different species
exactly
exactly and and and thinking about the
laws of physics and so forth
when when we came up with this motor
theory of vocal learning origin and how
it
could have happened uh and and also
uh prove using the phylogenetic tree
or with whole genomes that this is
independent origins of
in birds and in mammals uh it gave me
more a light bulb went off in my head
and said
heck this has to mean that not only
there are other planets
but maybe there's life on other planets
because if you're starting from the same
substrate
and just can naturally involve something
as complex as spoken language
uh or at least something close to it
multiple times
why can't you evolve something as
complex as life you know multiple times
this is a very good question we've also
talked uh with origins of life people so
so you're you're now leaning toward the
idea that life is ubiquitous in the in
the universe
i know this is a little aside but that's
okay that's what podcasts are for
yeah i i i won't go as far as saying
ubiquitous but i could go as far as
saying
as uh definitely more than an n of one
right
okay there's there's the big idea that
maybe there's
monocellular life all over the place but
it never got together to make
multicellular life
okay um i find that hard to believe
because
if uh cells like to communicate with
each other and they like to aggregate
you know so it would have to be mono
cellular life that does not
have the the selection for a
multi-cellular need
yeah yeah it took a long time though
right on earth like er life came to be
pretty quickly but the grouping together
took a long time
no i i would agree with that so so yeah
it's not a straightforward linear
function over time
it's to getting to the more complex life
form we are now
uh i just wish we humans would evolve a
little faster
considering our current politics yeah
there are there are things we but you
know evol
evolution is not directed as you know so
you know maybe evolving is not what we
want to do
right okay so but so back to the birds
just to just to uh
drive it home you know the fact that
it's whales and elephants and
and and humans that can vocal learn uh
clearly means that they don't have a
common ancestor it evolved independently
within that
those mammals did the vocal learning
also evolve independently
within the different bird species where
it happens i would say we don't have
evidence that vocal learning evolved
within the different bird species
but we do have evidence that it was lost
in some like the anna's hummingbird
and that it was lost in females of a
number of somber species and this is why
uh in uh there are some species out
there and we humans in the northern
hemisphere think
that most species only the male singing
the females don't it turns out
near the equator where most songbirds
are at both males and females learn how
to sing
uh the further you get away from the
equator the higher probability that
females lost the
building where there's been more of a
division of labor between the sexes
it's interesting yeah uh that that we
will learn something that useful and
then
lose it maybe this goes back to your
ideas about uh
i guess i guess you're could i put your
idea with the predators in the
phrasing it as there's a resource cost
in being able to have vocal learning and
you have to decide whether it's worth it
to your situation
exactly uh and that that resource comes
in two forms one is like i said for the
predators
you'll just be dead and the other is um
it takes a lot of energy uh glucose
atp and so forth uh in this brain
circuit
yeah it has very high firing rates and
one of the reasons why i think that's
the case is because the larynx muscles
besides the the ir lateral rectifier
muscles the larynx muscles
are the most rapidly firing muscles in
the body
so i think it takes a lot of actual real
energy for the body to actually produce
spoken language
and what is it that is the benefit to a
hummingbird or a parakeet uh to be able
to do this do they
do they vocally learn and use that in
social context to team
up if they do use it in social context
most species use it for mate attraction
and territorial defense the more varied
your vocalization the more likely you're
attracted mate so
because the more intelligent you sound
the more healthier you sound
is that the way it works okay some
species like chickeny
they will have particular calls and
learn calls
uh and uh pictures of those calls that
identify
particular predators in the area um
and you can get dolphins who will uh use
what they call signature whistles with
names for each other
so so you can imagine you know once you
get this form of communication
it's not visual it's it's auditory the
sound propagates long distance
so you can communicate with somebody a
long distance
uh without actually having to see them
you have a greater social
a network uh with this than
uh you get from vision alone or smell
actually it makes me
ask i mean is there a visual equivalent
of this question about
vocal learning i mean is the ability to
make gestures that have meaning
something that some species have and
others don't
yeah so the visual equivalent would be
uh sign gesturing
uh which which can be learned like like
a zebra finch
can learn it it puts it when it sings
with learned song to a female a male
sings to a female
it produces some body movement that we
call a courtship dance
that actual body movement is also
learned
uh and so and and you have that kind of
learning in
other species as well that don't produce
learned sounds right
so uh so yeah there is visual learning
through visual motor integration
uh but you need to see something close
to you in order to
see what that learned communication is
sure yeah
and you know these days in the pandemic
i mean who has time to look good and
and be visually appealing so i i get
that but
right right actually to another
perspective if if we only could sign
right uh but can't uh produce
learned sounds uh we couldn't
actually communicate with if i'm in the
kitchen and somebody else is in the
bathroom
right i can yell out to that person and
say
hey please bring me you know the towel
from the bathroom
right right but if i sign do a sign
please bring me a towel from the
bathroom that person can't hear me
yeah but i mean that it's sort of
battling in my mind
the idea that uh it's still so rare like
it would seem
like some herd of animals in the
savannah
um would find it very very useful to be
able to
warn about different things using actual
symbolic language
right unless the predators pick them off
yeah that's like
so the predators are the ones that so i
think yeah that's why i think the
selection
for it and their selection pressure
against it yeah okay good
good and this so you mentioned the idea
that it makes you sexier if you can talk
and you have a sweet tongued uh voice
etc
but my impression is that this is
something that uh evolutionary
biologists
struggle with the extent to which just
being more attractive to mates is
something that drives
um evolutionary pressures do we have we
learned more about that since i
my vague learnings from years ago yeah
yeah
i mean there is debate about it at the
same time i i can understand
i can understand the side of the debate
that says
propagating your species the survival of
your species
is being just as important as the
survival as the individual
uh how do you make your species survive
is you have sexual reproduction
yeah so the competition for that
survival of your own individual genes
is high and so anything that can help
that
including uh sounding intelligent and
sexy
uh i think will go a long way
interesting so that's that's a major
driver do you think not only in birds
but also
in uh in humans or or in elephants
yeah because i mean you know uh
you know brain over bronze is you know a
common statement
right both of them are are are seen as
you know selection traits you know of
how strong you are
as a volatile intelligent bar uh
and that intelligence correlates with
the spoken language abilities
in birds it's been shown that as
steve nowicki at duke university has
shown that
that if you uh you know nutritionally
deprive
a songbird at a young age
and then it grows up to be an adult it
sings what sounds like
maybe an impoverished song as a result
of that nutritional deprivation because
that nutritional deprivation impacted
the brain in a negative way
right females don't like that
impoverished song and that bird doesn't
get to pass on its genes
you know we just talked to david
eagleman about you know how the brain is
especially plastic at young ages and how
you learn things and then you
you lose the ability to learn them so i
guess what you're saying is that uh
songbirds also you know they have a
window in which they can learn
and it goes away maybe that's right
that's right yeah this critical period
uh like we humans have
when you learn best in an early age in
life uh and then it's harder to learn
uh news sounds later in life and for
some songbird they just can't
right and others they are able to like
humans but still not as good as when
they are
a young infant tis the season of giving
not just to your family and friends but
to charitable causes as well
the issue with giving to good causes of
course is knowing that your dollar goes
far
and that's why for a long time i've been
a fan of givewell.org
for over 10 years givewell has helped
donors find the charities and projects
that save and improve lives most per
dollar
using an evidence-based approach
givewell does an enormous amount of
research
looking at different charities and all
of that research is publicly available
for free on their website for you to go
check out
since 2010 givewell has helped over 50
000 donors direct over 500 million
dollars
to the most affected charities if you
want your donation to have even more
impact
act soon any of our listeners who become
new give well donors
will have their first donation matched
up to 250 dollars
when you go to givewell.org mindscape
and select podcast and mindscape at
checkout this matching offer is good for
as long as funds last so this is a
special chance
for even a small donation to make a big
impact get your first donation matched
up to 250 dollars when you go to
givewell.org mindscape
and select podcast and mindscape at
checkout
in some sense the fact that songbirds
also have this ability to do vocal
learning is a boon for scientists like
you
because you can study the actual brains
of songbirds with a lot less restriction
than
the brains of human beings or something
like that that that's right
and uh in one form you you would think
well it's because it's independent it's
going to be different
and therefore it may not be relevant to
a human
spoken language uh but we're finding
because things that evolve
independently can evolve it in a similar
way
uh it does mean that since it's similar
you can learn
about the human uh mechanisms from
studying these animals
and this is what we've been discovering
right so when you say that there is this
motor circuit that
that helps us control our vocalizations
and and helps us learn
is it is it do we say it's the same
motor circuit in a parakeet in the human
or uh similar related well we say it's
an analogous one
okay um so the word analogy
or analogous means that it it's
independently evolved but in a similar
way
and homologous means it's the same okay
uh
so in in actuality if this motor theory
of vocal learning origin is true
uh it would mean that the surrounding
motor circuit
found in all vertebrates for learning
how to move
other parts of the body that's homology
and we would call that a deep homology
because it gave rise to the analogous
circuit
for speech okay so so so
there's there is an aspect that is that
is homologous which is the stronger form
uh than simply analogous that's right
right so the
the motor pathway for learning is is
homologous
deep homology and the analogous one that
it came out of
right is the motor is the speech pathway
okay very good
and i mean maybe let's go into some
details about how you know
something like that like how do you
learn what's going on in the brain of uh
parakeet
we we have different kinds of
experiments one is
uh people can you know put electrodes in
the brain
uh like when patients are undergoing
surgery they put electrodes and they
find out the speech areas
and they ask the person to speak so they
don't want to remove that part of the
brain
when a person is uh you know trying to
remove a tumor or
a region that causes epilepsy so you put
electrodes and when a person speaks like
we're doing now the neurons
light up the reaction potentials
electrical currents paths from one
neuron to another
that control that behavior but you can
do the same thing with these animals
and record while they're singing
the other is we have there are certain
genes in the brain that respond
to that activity that electrical act
changes in the brain
uh their their messenger rna and protein
products go up or down
and we can use this what's like a
molecular mapping tool
uh to identify brain areas that are
active during particular behaviors
and how do you know what brain area is
expressing a gene
um we we do have in that case we do have
to dissect the brain out after
uh you know they're vocalizing right and
we measure
uh using techniques like immunostatic
chemistry it's called or in future
organization
these are techniques where we take a
probe in a test tube that we make to a
particular gene
and then we bind it to the tissue and we
can measure the gene product
with that probe and find out what brain
area is was active
so maybe just for uh sort of
intellectual interest reasons like it
sounds like
you have a lab right or maybe you have
multiple labs and you're doing
all sorts of different kinds of things
sometimes you're dissecting birds and
sometimes you're
training them what's going on in the
different parts of your lab
yeah so so i actually have three
different lab spaces one we call the
neurogenetics of language lab
where here we're trying to uh and i'm
sitting in my office of that lab now
where we tried to uh figure out the
genetics behind spoken language what is
setting up those brain circuits
what's similar to what we see in the
birds what we can learn from the birds
and humans
and the circuitry the
electrophysiological
activity in them and the behavior uh so
we're doing all of that
and and on top of trying to figure out
how it works
we have hypothesis of how it works uh
and what genes
are specialized in the brain to make
this work in the in
in uh in humans in um in these songbirds
and what we're trying to do is take the
human version of those genes and put
them in the mouse brain
a species that can't imitate sounds the
way we do
to see to test the hypothesis if we take
the human version of these genes that
causes this connectivity
will we get the malice to actually learn
how to imitate sounds
and the answer is not there yet okay
so so far we've modified one gene and
it's we don't think it's enough we've
we've got to modify dozens of genes we
think
uh we also have a genome go ahead
i'm just i mean i'm interested so you
know we we
we find a gene in human beings that is
related to our vocal learning
capabilities
and you're inserting it literally into
the mouse genome
yeah so far what we're except for this
sr gap 2 gene which i don't think is
directly related to language right
we're not finding that humans
and sombers and parrots have extra genes
that we think is associated with
language
we think it's modification of existing
genes okay
the only case that we're looking for
extra genes could there be extra copies
of a gene that causes brain pathway
duplication but even if that were
occurring
we're seeing existing genes that we can
find in mind we can find in birds we can
find in reptiles and then fish
have been modified in a similar way in
humans and songbirds
okay so that's that's dramatic i want to
make sure that i'm not uh over
emphasizing it so for one thing i think
maybe people don't understand
the extent to which there's overlap
between the genes
of a songbird the gene of a human being
like uh
i mean how similar are those two things
because they look different a a bird
looks very different from a person
yeah even though a bird looks very
different from a person
over 80 percent of our genes are or the
same genes
uh they're just regulated in different
ways that then and and do have different
g
protein coding sequences to them as well
uh
divergence in that but they're regulated
in different ways that causes a bird
there to be a bird in the mammal to be a
mammal
so when you do when you say that the
motor pathway
uh is parts of it homologous parts of it
analogous
between songbirds and humans um
can you you can sort of pinpoint that at
the gene
level yes yes because well we can
based upon the connectivity we can tell
where
we can call this a motor pathway because
it's synapsing onto
it's making connections to neurons that
eventually control the muscles
the other is certain genes that are
expressed in the motor pathway
of birds we can see it in mammal brain
as well
my mind you're going to say that the
bird brain the organization of the
cortex part of the bird brain they do
have a cortex
but it's not layered as it was in humans
the cells are actually clustered in
their organization
so it actually has a different cellular
organization
even though it's an ancient motor
learning pathway
right got it but but it does it does
raise this possibility maybe this is
what you already just said with the mice
that um the same genes exist in all
sorts of species that don't have
vocal learning but if you can just
fiddle with how they're expressed or not
you can give them that ability
that's right that's right so so some
biologists like to think of this as the
toolkit
even though we have a a lot of species
including us have these big giant
genomes of lots of dna but only
20 000 protein coding genes right right
uh we can if we if if nature wanted to
it can fit a hundred times that many
genes inside our genome
with a lot of this intergenic regions
for regulation
and and duplications of for uh you know
or just
housing viruses and keeping them quiet
in arduino
so so so nature has a way of taking a
limited set of 20 000 genes
as a tool kit like think about 20 000
tools and then use them in different
ways to control different kind of
connections in the brain
or different kinds of cell types in the
body right
i think this was uh one of the points
made by my evil twin sean b
carroll uh we had him on the podcast yes
i know who he is
yes he talks about the toolkit it's the
same toolkit there you mean the same
thing
that's right so the same toolkit is
being used to generate the spoken
language pathway
i see okay so now you're you're making
uh super mice that can talk to each
other and plot our ultimate downfall
well think about this parrots can also
imitate us and they're they're
apparently not taking over the world
that's true but the mice yeah yeah i
don't know i would i would worry about
the mice a little bit
but okay but these are early days with
the mice you're trying to explore
how you can i mean how do you do it how
what exactly do you fiddle with in the
genome is it do you
change the gene somewhere to change the
expression elsewhere or do you just put
different chemicals in the environment
we're trying to change the expression
locally in
circuits in the brain that control vocal
behavior and not change it elsewhere
uh and so we're trying to upregulate or
down regulate certain gene products that
control
uh connections and the one connection
we're trying to modify the most
is one that can that the cortex in the
in the forebrain
has a direct control of the neurons that
that modulate the muscles for
vocalizations
and other species we don't get that
direct connection
uh or even any connection at all uh in
uh
humans and some birds it's a huge robust
connection from
from the forebrain okay so you sort of
have a target to shoot for in some sense
that's right we have targeted
connections we're trying to change in
the brain
and all the sounds from the point of
view of you know any scientist 20 years
ago to be
incredibly science fictiony right like
the ability to really
go in there and zero in on genes and
turn them on and off uh
is is rapid progress in the field as far
as i can tell
yes um and i would still say at this
point it's still science picturing me
but i've been able and other colleagues
of mine have been able to come up
with clear hypotheses that if
if tested and work out actually we'll
we'll get us there
uh you know if things really work this
way uh
20 years ago we didn't have a clear
hypothesis right so
so so now we're based upon the data
we've collected in other labs have
collected we can formulate this
hypothesis
and say wow this is a crazy idea but
let's go ahead and
get some people to give us money to try
it and that that's what has
happened well we've had the human genome
project but we don't have you know the
entire
animal kingdom genome project yet is
that something that we're thinking about
well yes uh you know about the last
phases i have and this
all these questions now led to one line
space my second lab space is the
vertebrae genome lab
being run by with me and another
colleague uh
olivier federigo uh and um
there guess what i've now become chair
of a large international consortium
whose mission it is to sequence the
genomes of all vertebrate species on the
planet so all animals
oh okay and to do it at high quality
because we found that if you don't have
high quality genomes
meaning that pieces are assembled
correctly without
gaps and without errors in them uh
you can you can uh do better biological
investigations
i said why not just do that not only for
the vocal earners but let's just do it
for all species on the planet
and then you can i mean presumably this
is a giant database uh
this is just an enormous amount of
computational resources yeah
that's right exactly so we don't have
the compute
the computational ability to do all that
right now
we don't have the money to actually
generate all the data
but we have will and we have a path
forward and we've
we've we've now are in phase one of 216
species representing all vertebrate
orders
where we have found the money for that
first phase and we're going to use that
as a sounding board to say
hey world please give us the rest of the
money to complete the entire project
and eventually not for just all
vertebrate for an earth biogenome
project
uh being led by harris lewin for all
eukaryotic species on the planet
eukaryotic species
okay so we'll count as insects that's
right
right and so just again for the cultural
enrichment purposes
uh my scientific life my team
is like typically me and a postdoc and a
few students
how how big is all these labs that you
that you have and
are trying to control and i do have one
more which is a field research center
upstate new york uh
part of the rockefeller university where
we do field work uh
on different species recording their
songs in the wild and
looking at the the different species
have different repertoire compositions
some are more complex you know many
you know 100 songs some just sing one
and so
um so i would say my team amongst these
three lab space words is a total of
close to 30 people
okay with the neuroscience space being
at least half
more than half of those people uh
and um the the international consortiums
that i'm part of for the uh
vertebrate genomes project earth
biogenome project
uh and also one for collaborating on
uh um grain evolution across species
with the allen institute and others
each one of those well the the the
genome one itself alone
is well over 200 people in 80 countries
uh as of right now and it grows every
week
uh and the uh the neuroscience brain
evolution one is like four labs
uh each one of them having anywhere from
you know
seven to uh my lab having 30 people
and the allen institute they have
hundreds yeah you're not quite up to the
level of the experimental particle
physicist with 5000 people in the
collaboration but it's clear that's the
direction in which things are going
but i but i've taken some inspiration
from them uh
i was invited uh years ago to the
american astronaut anarchical society
to give a keynote lecture on the
evolution of language and i'm like
why do astronomers want to know about uh
you know
the brain and how it evolved and so
forth uh and i can see why now when i
came up with this idea of
thinking that life is on other planets
when i can understand how language
evolves more than once
yeah yeah exactly that that's right and
what is the
um what kinds of things can we learn
once we get the entire vertebrate genome
or the set of them all uh sequence like
what are the questions you're
immediately asking comparing between
species
yeah so so that's that's that's what
i've been hoping is that they're going
to be questions that people will think
of that they never would think of before
because they never thought in their
lifetime right
not only having a human genome they have
the genome of all life on earth
uh and so it will become the
uh you don't have to sequence anymore
what what what we'll need to do is
is create a database of traits
of all these different species and with
a database of traits in a database of
their genetic codes
that'll make it a lot easier to figure
out
what kind of genes you need to create
certain drugs against certain diseases
because there will be certain lots of
species that are resistant to a disease
and others that are not
and you'll be able to figure that out
relatively quickly
with that that information uh i think
we'll be able to define what is really a
species
and when to call a species of species or
as opposed to a subspecies or
or you know a strain i think we'll be
able to
um really understand evolution a lot
better than we do now
uh and um we'll be able to
really uh uh figure out the
the tree of life a lot more accurately
than we have now
so for example i mean i i thought that
the tree of life is something we
understood pretty well
are we still lacking in certain
important aspects there
yes uh i i thought we did too
until i you know discovered that these
vocal learning species
all have uh like i said as especially
amongst the birds very similar brain
pathways
that started me and other people
questioning did they have a single
origin
and for the songbirds parrots and
hummingbirds
and um so when i started then looking at
the literature and
every year every other year the bird
tree the family tree of birds was
changing
owls going from one position to another
uh
hummingbirds was going from one position
to another and i said wait a minute
these guys don't know what they're
talking about
you know the tree is not really set and
that's when we got
that's when we decided to do whole
genomes and we changed the bird tree
once again
which is now more stable in its in the
publication since we have the whole
genome
so no the tree of life is not resolved
it's far from resolved
but the genome project would be exactly
the kind of thing you need to do that
you don't even sort of need to look at
what they look like anymore you can just
trace
in the genomes what came from what is
that a safe way
okay that's right and and and it's not
going to be a straightforward
what we call bifurcating free where you
have parents give rise to children
who you know or you can go from the
children to the parents that are
grandparents and so forth
there's going to be interrelationships
uh
and the weight and so it's going to be
partially network like and the way i put
it
i put that in for humans even amongst
the vocal learning species as well but
for humans
is that um you're not my father or my
parent and so forth right but we're all
cousins
yeah people don't realize we're all
cousins we're all related to each other
by being cousins and if we sequence the
genome of every person on the planet
we can figure out what our cousin of
relationships are to everybody else
right and when we because i'm again
naive about this i mean when we get the
genome for a species like when i first
heard that we were doing the human
genome project my reaction was
but human beings have different genomes
right we're genetically not identical to
each other and
is the difference that there are certain
broad genes that we do
exactly share and then there are minor
differences here and there uh
do we do we map down to the individual
base pairs of dna or is it cruder than
that
yeah and that's another project that i
got involved with as well
called the pan-human genome project
where
we predict if you sequence the genomes
of about 300 people
representing roughly 350 different
populations or ethnic groups on the
planet
that you'll you'll basically determine
what is
what is the conserved human genome that
everybody shares and then what is
different right from one group to
another
and uh we don't know the answer to that
like how much
what is the percent that is
unequivocally human that will
that once that sequence changes we're no
longer human
uh and we're getting close to knowing
that but we don't really know the answer
to be able for me to answer that
question in the percentage manner
but we do know that it has to exist
right what is the
what is the other primate that is
probably closest to human beings
genetically
is the closest relative closest living
okay
and so then the other thing we'd want to
know is how different we are from the
chimpanzees not just how different we
are from each other right
there's some genes that are probably
always different between humans and
chimpanzees but always the same among
humans
that's right and one of those is uh the
essar gap 2 gene that i mentioned to you
that keeps our brain in a more immature
state compared to chimpanzees and other
animals
another one close to home for me is fox
p2
it's a transcription factor that
regulates other genes that
it has two nucleotide mutations
just two amino acid differences that you
don't see in champs or many
or most other uh vertebrate species
that we think somehow enhances uh spoken
language circuits to function the way
they do
how i mean to what extent can we think
about spoken language
as the thing that makes us special i
mean it's clearly one of the things
do you uh think that is one of the main
things that really
set humans on this slightly different
trajectory
yeah so so you asked about a little
while ago about the uh
even amongst the vocal learners are
there differences and they are
and so i think it's there are
differences of degree for almost
everything and that that includes spoken
language
so we are special uh
for spoken language but the specialty is
not
have and have not okay the specialty is
that we're more
much more far advanced for this ability
than even the other vocal learners so
we're just
better at making the sounds or creating
them in different patterns
yeah we're better at making i won't say
exactly better at making them because
you can get some parents producing
sounds in the ways we can't yeah that's
true right
uh and i challenge anybody to produce
parrot warble song with their
with their vocal learning abilities uh
but
we are better at uh recombining them and
better at using our sounds
for various different things like
writing reading uh
forming new concepts and so on i mean
given everything that you've learned
about
uh language and vocal learning what does
this teach us about old ideas from noam
chomsky or you know what i learned about
uh from stephen pinker's books about
the language instinct is that is that a
good way of thinking about things that
we have some
built-in grammar choices in our brain or
is that kind of outdated
yeah two things coming from those two
people and and also
the linguistic community in general the
language instinct uh
this um i i there there is a there is a
truth to that in the sense that we have
a genetic predisposition to learn how to
imitate sounds
right the brain pathway that controls
spoken language
is genetically determined what it does
and what it imitates is not genetically
determined that we learn culturally
right right so this the second thing is
coming out of that
chomsky is that um there's a language
module in the brain
uh that then controls the vocal pathway
and the auditory pathway
telling it what to do and how to process
speech and sounds
i disagree with that i don't think
there's good evidence for a separate
language module
i think the brain pathway that's
actually uh controlling the
the grammar the syntax and the and so
forth is the
spoken language pathway itself is the
motor learning pathway that i've talked
about
this whole time and the other pathway
that controls perception of the sounds
is the auditory pathway including
wernicke's area that i believe exists in
all these vertical species at least
dogs yeah and cocoa and chickens and so
forth
and this is not unique it's already
there it feeds into a motor learning
pathway but it's already there
and it's not a separate language module
and this is why dogs can understand
rudimentary
human speech okay i mean i guess this is
this is a good place to sort of uh uh
wind things down you know we let our
hair down at the end of the podcast and
think about the relationship between uh
language and intelligence more broadly
like
the first thing that people would say if
you said what makes human beings
different than other animals is that
we're smarter right
but clearly this language ability that
we share with this kind of somewhat
random collection of other
animals is also kind of important is
there some
you know uh uh
what is the right word uh evolutionary
pressure that sort of
increases intelligence because we
learned these vocal abilities or vice
versa
or what's going on yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna say i'm not gonna put a whole
lot of confidence in what i'm about to
say but i'm gonna say it still hasn't
been disproven and it's your
testing further and i won't be the first
to say this but i'm going to say it more
in a unique way
and that is i don't think it's i want i
don't want to call it language ability
associated with greater intelligence i'm
going to call it vocal learning ability
associated with greater intelligence and
in why
that could have occurred is that vocal
learning
leads to greater social communication
right and greater social communication
i think than selects for greater
intelligence
in in that sequence of order and that
the language
ability in other words the ability to
communicate in a
syntactical meaning manner with like
sign gesturing
or even olfaction or vision already
exists
in many species but i don't think it's
selecting for greater intelligence
i think it's the particularly the vocal
learned communication it's selecting for
it
i guess maybe let's throw something out
there i mean in the
list of other species that have this
vocal learning ability whether it's
elephants or bats or whales or birds
we're the only ones that have fingers
whereas other primates have fingers or
you know even other
mammals have fingers and can can grasp
things but they don't have
vocal learning is there some combination
of this ability to uh
speak and learn language sounds but and
also be able to manipulate our
environment in delicate ways that maybe
makes intelligence a useful quality in
ways that it's it's
less obviously useful to evolution in
other contexts
that's that's an interest i haven't
thought about that this is the very
first time someone even brought that
idea up to me
uh that's an interesting idea i like it
that
right that you know in addition to our
greater social communication through
vocal learning we do
now use our hands in a manipulative way
yeah
that can manipulate the environment more
than the other vocal earners
and if parrots had hands maybe they
would be able to take over the world
i mean they can fly they can clearly
take over the world much more easily
than we can if they can build things
right that's not a uh that's that's a
even a more hand waving idea but i i
don't want to shut it down i i think
that's a plausible thing to
to uh you know ponder on more
well in that case i definitely want to
end this podcast because this is a high
note that we're not gonna
we're not gonna we're not gonna get
higher then but but i'd like you know i
mean maybe i'll give you the last word
here but you know
one of the things about evolution is not
just that there are random mutations
that leads us crazy places but
they're weird synchronizations as we've
already said between different things
whether it's having fingers and
vocalizing and learning and so forth and
uh
i mean how does it does what
where what is the role of abstract
thought in all of this is
is this something that uh is unique to
humans and is if we give some credit
to our ability to vocalize or is this
once again something where we're just
giving ourselves too much credit because
we're ourselves
i think this is one of those things
where the truth is in the middle
uh that we do give ourselves too much
credit for uh but
i do think we have a greater capacity
for abstract thought and the reason why
is that i think thought is happening in
our auditory our visual pathways
as well as in outreach pathways and when
we have thought
through our speech pathways we are
talking to ourselves we're not actually
producing the sounds
but we're talking in our head and that
speech that's being produced in our head
is be sent to the hearing pathway the
auditory pathway
to hear what we say so we have this
greater capacity for thinking
uh but i don't think we're the only ones
with that ability
and so i think parrots will talk in
their own heads but a dog will only hear
in its own head it won't talk in a
godhead
well that's fascinating that's a really
really good way to put it uh
i i on an earlier podcast with carl
fristan i
contrasted my two cats because i think
they have very different intellectual
abilities
one really seems to have an inner life
and the other one doesn't so
i think that uh i i i hope that uh
biologists and neuroscientists like like
yourself can learn more about the inner
lives of all sorts of animals going
forward
if we can get them to talk we could be
able to do that well you're going to
change their genome so they can do that
that's going to revolutionize the world
all right
eric jarvis thanks very much this is a
fascinating conversation thanks for
being on mindscape
you're welcome
[Music]
you